on parle tout de suite avec carlo
alberto brusa avocat au barreau de paris
président de l'association réaction 1,19
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france cette question
tout simplement pourquoi s'opposer au
port obligatoire du masque alors il vous
présentez jeu votre je trouve que votre
journaliste magnifiquement présenté la
situation est la synthèse est tout à
fait exact
il n'y a pas deux il faut pas placer ce
clivage oui au masque non au masque il
faut avoir des réponses juridiques cela
veut dire quoi
ah mince que le porte quand cela est
vraiment nécessaire
quand il répond aux besoins de santé
publique
or aujourd'hui quand monsieur casalino
dit il faut porter le masque
c'est une affirmation l'avocat et le
jury se pose la question pourquoi
quels sont les critères objectifs de
santé qui vont permettre de dire que je
dois porter le masque tout le temps à
l'intérieur dans une entreprise dans une
école à l'extérieur ce sont des
questions qui sont aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas traités de manière juridique et
sont traités de manière impressionniste
et ça c'est un problème extrêmement
important parce que le jury se ne
s'interroge pas sur une opportunité
médical juristes se pose la question
dans le principe de l'égalité des choses
c'est à dire qui a décidé quoi pourquoi
on a décidé comment le décider et quels
sont les moyens juridiques qu'on a mis
en oeuvre pour atteindre un certain
résultat et c'est ça et ceci c'est le
morceau ciel parce que je prends
l'exemple la copie 19 que jusqu'à 22
heures
22h52 pas marseille elle est dangereuse
elle n'est pas dangereuse à partir de 23
heures
c'est là qu'il commence à s'outiller
sont tous les glaces de la république
là ce sont des choses qui n'ont pas de
réponse juridique c'est un préfet qui se
réveille le matin et qui décide d'aller
mettre fin à une liberté qui a la
liberté du commerce et de l'industrie en
décidant que votre 3e année de la
réponse juridique on vous comprend bien
il ya une réponse aussi médicale à cette
urgence de la pandémie vous avez
certainement peut-être entendu les
chiffres que nous avons donné au début
de cette édition
recrudescence des contaminations
inquiétante on approche vraiment
rapidement de la rentrée maintenant est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une nécessité tout de
même de choisir finalement entre les
libertés individuelles et la
responsabilité collective
face au danger que représente le kobe de
vous savez votre votre phrase sur le
plan de principe elle est tout à fait
acceptable elles mêmes recevable il
s'agit pas d'une liberté individuelle
face aux responsabilités collectives
il s'agit plutôt de savoir si
effectivement porter le masque que tout
la journée le porter à l'extérieur est
vraiment utile et fait de moi quelqu'un
qui respecte l'autre hui pourquoi parce
que aujourd'hui même la plupart des
médecins qui disait qu'il fallait porter
en permanence de masse qui disent qu'à
l'extérieur
elle est quasiment casey quasiment
inutile vous prenez un pays comme
l'espagne l'allié des études qui vont
être faites qui a imposé le mal que moi
j'étais en espagne je vais effectivement
quasiment 100% de la population
espagnole porte le masque et avec une
présence policière près pente et vous
voyez que l'espagne c'est quand même un
des pays les plus frappés par cette
évolution des contaminations et puis
attention la contamination n'est pas en
tant que tel à l'indicateur exhaustif de
la pandémie
ce qui compte ce sont les
hospitalisations et ce sont les décès si
tous les soirs nous donner le bulletin
de la copie de données aussi deux
bulletins d accidents de la circulation
donné le bulletin des gens qui meurent
de cancer donner des butins aujourd'hui
de tout ce qui n'a pas été fait pendant
le confinement des gens qui sont décédés
par d'autres maladies qui ne sont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas été soignées
nous nous sommes aujourd'hui de face un
problème d'une sorte de idolâtrie de la
santé publique
on a remplacé le mot liberté par le mot
santé sur le fronton du palais nous
sommes dirigé aujourd'hui par le haut
conseil de santé et pas par une
politique parlementaire fixée par les
représentants du peuple qui discutent
crif les schistes qui fixe des critères
objectifs pour faire face à l'épidémie
et puis j'ai fermé les ré sur un point
médical vous parler du respect
aujourd'hui j'attire votre attention
qu'aujourd'hui le problème de coût de la
comédie de touche
neuf personnes sur dix qui ont plus de
65 ans que de 0 à 20 ans il n'y a
c'est contre il nous a juste ce chiffre
pour commencer vos propos en quelques
mois le co vie de 19 en france 5 en
france on sait que est aussi un bilan
très lourd ailleurs en europe et dans le
monde
c'est plus de 30000 morts quand même a
tonné
trente mille morts j'attire votre
attention que vous avez la moitié en
quelques mois ce sont dans les ehpad
il ya eu un choix de confinement qui a
été fait choix qu'aujourd'hui a été
critiqué parce que il n'a pas produit
ses effets comme pouvait lire et sens du
mot utile parlons des ehpad
on a confiné on a bloqué dans les
annales de n'avait pas de test alors
qu'il fallait plutôt sortir faire des
tests sur tirer personnes et on a donc
la moitié de ces personnes se sentent
dépassés sont des maisons de retraite
des personnes très âgées avec des
comorbidités vous à vous étiez présent
rassemblement qui masque parisien
aujourd'hui d'abord est-ce qu'il ya une
communauté anti masquant kitty qui se
met réellement en place et on sait qu'il
ya des des des amendes qui sont prévues
pour les personnes qui ne vont pas
porter le masque est ce que là il y aura
des recours juridiques que vous prévoyez
bien sûr les masques ferro loger les
hommes de cotter infligé de 135 euros et
d'ailleurs où un gendarme à volume en
plus j'ai un masque parce que je portais
le masque sous le nez alors que la
limite je suis quasiment ball élèves de
la république eh bien ils seront cotés
c'est parce que nous considérons que il
y a des le principe de l'égalité qui
n'est pas respectée qu'une amende de 105
euros qui est envisagée pour une période
deux urgences sanitaires ne peut pas
s'appliquer par analogie à une période
où ne sont pas il y aura d'autres
monnier de droit de toute façon il ya je
me permets de vous dire une chose
j'ai ce n'est pas un réaction 19 qui
organisait la manifestation aujourd'hui
je trouve que l'accueil était effrayant
effrayant
il y avait un déploiement de policiers
de gendarmes abandonnées au nord après
une remis après les personnes qui
étaient présentes étaient menacés les
gens avaient peur de s'approcher
on sent quand même une volonté très très
forte d'empêcher la liberté d'expression
parce que les gens qui étaient là
étaient des gens pacifiques des gens qui
voulait seulement exprimer comme ils ont
le droit leur contrariété à une vision
unique en france la liberté d'expression
la libye
thénot cugn en est une un principe
constitutionnel savait par dix les
droits de l'homme et on a l'impression
que dès que quelqu'un ose dire quelque
chose de différent
il devient tout de suite un complotiste
quelqu'un qui veut porter atteinte au
gouvernement aux fondements pas du tout
les gens ont le droit de s'exprimer
je n'ai pas eu bien sûr après ils
peuvent se mélanger des thématiques qui
sont parfois un peu farfelue mais la
base c'est avant tout ce que depuis la
plus conne virus il y a actuellement une
situation de atteinte aux valeurs
constitutionnelles et au principe des
libertés essentielles avec un transfert
du pouvoir politique c'est à dire
parlementaire en soi même de l'exécutif
et ça c'est tout ce qui se passe et ce
prix mais aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement le masque merci la légalité
carlo alberto brusa on vous a permis de
vous exprimer merci d'avoir à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris présidents
d'associations réaction à 19